wait Sophia so is it true your husband
this is like one of my favorite things
your husband Joe holds a Dungeons &
Dragons club in your house I mean these
photos and I actually once I heard about
this actually do you play do you play
this I want to I was I'm such a nerd
alert like I literally went down a
little rabbit hole of like watching it
on YouTube like him talking about who's
come in and out of the game and it's
like the most random group of people so
this is super weird they're really weird
here in the house I mean now now that
they are team they're doing it on soon
so they have still been playing it's
crazy because they couldn't do something
this game for like six seven hours and
they sing they clap they I don't know
what they're doing down there it's like
a something really weird that I can't
understand but it sounds fun you know
most people who play Dungeons & Dragons
don't even meet pretty girls to marry
one you ended up with the guy that plays
done Joe is a complete nerd I always
tell him that he's trusting the wrong
looks like a man's club it looks like
Little Rascals like women aren't invited
know that they're being girls playing
here no I mean it's a percentage but yes
they do come and play you subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going